the rockies are going to counter with
john gray and john in his first three
starts billy has fashioned a 287 earned
run ever
and this should be two
easy double play six four three that
ends the inning there was a walk to
brantley rockies will get ready to hit
24 year old luis garcia
is on the bound if that name rings
familiar
well it should because he started an
elimination game
in the alcs game six which houston would
go on to win and force the game seven
which tampa uh obviously won but uh this
kid was thrown into the fire very early
in his career there's a pitch for a
strike and a throw to second strike him
out throw him out double play
welcome back machete
sounds like there's some astros fans
there
that was a beautiful thing luis garcia
getting back in the zone with that 94
mile an hour fastball to get the called
third and then the machete shows up and
throws a dart down to second base
[Music]
all sent the other way and brantley has
the first hit of the night for the
houston astros first hit of the game for
either side
of course it's michael brantley down in
the count to two strikes
3-2
strike three on bregman
third strikeout for gray
[Applause]
swing on and missed and correa's got
john reach back got 95.
[Applause]
working back fly ball to shallow center
and it is going to drop in no man's land
and top here with no uncovered second
dives in
safely
and that's a wonderful heads-up play by
rival
because
he noticed both middle infielders had
gone out no one was covering second base
so it's a blue double for rival tapia
got it with a fastball
luis garcia knew that was important a
little fist pump after that strikeout
that's his fifth
two away in the inning
rusty baker locked in on that heater
first pitch swinging diaz off the glove
of the third baseman fuentes and that'll
cost
the rockies a base runner
diaz reaches on what should be an error
on the rocky's third baseman
02 maldonado
[Applause]
it's like there was still hot dog
wrappers this ball's crushed to right
center field dazza has it off the base
of the wall on one hop and he is going
to shut it down at second with a one-out
double
so the rocky's second hit
another double and this one was legit
ball's hit hard and michael brantley is
on base yet again
it doesn't matter if it's 75 or 35
michael brantley can just flat out hit
so the astros have a runner to second
base for the first time tonight see if
carlos correa can cash it in with a two
out rbi here
carlos to right field this ball has a
chance to get down it does all the way
to the corner that will score michael
brantley carlos correa into second base
rbi double astros on the board one
nothing
big hit with two outs
[Applause]
and trevor pope says to right it's gonna
drop off the end of the bat
the rockies have two on with two outs
and they're half of the six
and brian agree who has been summoned
and he'll face cj crow
2-1 hammer to center field
straw leaps can't catch it one runner
scored blackman gets a green light
cj crone has driven in two and the
rockies lead it two to one
his biggest at bat
of the young season in a new uniform for
c.j crowe so one out in the seventh for
nunez who's over one with a walk it was
an intentional walk back in the fifth
2-1 pitch is hit high and deep to right
center field it is over and out of here
off the back wall of the rockies bullpen
three to one rockies as nunez unloads
he doesn't hit any cheapies either you
notice that
four homers and they have all been
cagonged
[Applause]
pitch to mcmahon is hit to the left side
and through for a base hit
mack beats the shift
gets hit number six for colorado
cj crone who doubled over the head of
the center fielder straw last time up to
put the rockies into the lead would love
to pad
the advantage here speaking of homers
it's got a chance
gone
three-run home run cj crone
have a night cj
first home run in a rockies uni and now
colorado has broken it wide open
[Applause]
popped high in the air
coming on tucker calls off everybody
goes to the ground and makes a nice
catch
brown's probably a little more frozen
than usual but he bounces up and he
looks like he's okay but a big three-run
blast by cj crone gives the rockies a
6-1 lead heading to the night
bard the closer averages almost 98.
correa got on top of that fastball and
got it past trevor story
so carlos ends up with a two-hit knight
that's got to be a base hit you would
think
michael brantley has three hits
so those two have combined for all the
astros hits this evening
stevenson delivers swing and a miss he
got him with the slider
out number two
when robert stevenson has the feel and
command of that pitch
it is really a big weapon that ball
struck well by diaz to right center
field and this ball is off the wall
correa is going to get to third and be
waved around blackman's throw will be
cut off on the infield carlos correa
scores a led miss diaz with a double off
the right center field wall to make it a
6-2 game
and
back to the middle of the diamond should
be the end of the ball game it is
well done by fuentes well done by the
rockies tonight they snap that nine-game
losing streak to houston colorado wins
it behind john gray
six to two john's now two and one luis
garcia pitched well but he suffers the
loss he is oh and one and cj crone the
hitting start tonight
five rbi ball game including his first
home run in a rockies uniform again the
final score colorado six houston two